c'est la consternation à la prairie au
sud de montréal au lendemain de la mort
subite de la mairesse lucie roussel
elle faisait du jardinage air à son
chalet de l'estrie lorsqu'elle a été
piquée par plusieurs guette
il semble qu'elles n'étaient pas
allergique aux piqûres de guêpes les
ambulanciers lui ont rapidement
administrés de les people
ce médicament qui peut aider à diminuer
la rédaction la réaction allergique mais
en vain lussier roussel était âgé de 51
ans
elle laisse dans le deuil sa fille de 18
ans et son fils de 19 ans qui avait déjà
perdu leur père emporté subitement par
une crise cardiaque en 2009 à l'âge de
47 ans on va en parler de septembre
cette situation d'ici peu particulière
avec la docteure rejoignent blais de
l'hôpital saint françois d'assise à
québec
johan blake qui avait été désigné en
2011 médecin famille de l'année par le
collège des médecins de famille au
canada ont fait appel à votre expertise
madame blais comment on peut expliquer
une telle mort si on nous dit qu'elles
n'étaient pas allergique écouter dans un
premier temps brigitte comme est témoin
de présenter mes sympathies à tous les
proches de la famille roussel et à la
famille roussel bien sûr c'est assez
tragique effectivement avec ce que vous
avez dit il ne semblait pas allergique
aux piqûres de la piqûre de guêpe
donc ce qui est paul mathieu arriver
c'est qu'elle a quand même un choc
anaphylactique due au fait qu'elle a eu
de nombreuses piqûres de guêpes
lorsqu'on peint en nommer le pied sur un
eagle
comprenez que les ouvrières se
déchaînent pour essayer d'atteindre la
personne qui les a attaqués alors le
problème des 50 100 150 piqûre puis à ce
moment là ça devient toxique
est-ce que c'est fréquent c'est pas
fréquent on dit qu'il ya près de 2% de
la population qui font des réactions
allergiques extrême aux piqûres de galp
c'est sûr que faut comprendre la façon
dont ça se fait ce que lorsqu'on est
piqué on libère de l'histamine qui est
une substance qui qui est libérée dans
toutes les réactions allergiques quand
c'est des piqûres de guêpes ou
d'insectes
elle se libère sous la peau mais si vous
avez beaucoup beaucoup de piqûres ou que
vous êtes allergique à ce moment là
cette substance la se libère aussi au
niveau des poumons et au niveau des
autres organes au niveau des branches
donc c'est ce que ça fait c'est que ça
amène vraiment un problème de
deux voies respiratoires entre autres
avec une diminution de la tension
artérielle une augmentation de la
fréquence cardiaque éventuellement un
arrêt respiratoire
c'est probablement ce qui est arrivé à
madame bruxelles alors l'ours bourse
elle était il ya beaucoup de gens qui
font du jardinage à des gens qui vont en
forêt qui font du camping est ce qu'il
ya des endroits où on est davantage
exposé aux gays mais vous savez les
gains que ce on en trouve dans
différents endroits
et puis un ippon à voir évidemment dans
les arbres il peut en avoir en dessous
des toits de l'aider maison il peut en
avoir dans les greniers mais quand à
voir aussi dans les dents les espèces de
tunnels souterrains qui sont abandonnés
par des rongeurs et les gags font leur
nid dans ces espèces de d'entrée
souterraine là donc il faut se méfier et
effectivement vérifier autour de notre
chalet ou de notre maison
s'il pas un petit accumulation de roche
à l'entrée d'un trou parce qu'il peut
avoir une idée de nids de guêpes
effectivement à l'entrée bon est ce
qu'il faut pour pour prévenir ce genre
de situation là est-ce qu'on peut
recommander quelque chose aux gens par
exemple parce qu'il est préférable de
marché dans les sentiers lorsqu'on va en
forêt je pense que oui effectivement
associé une très bonne recommandation de
dire aux gens de marcher dans les
sentiers et vérifier quand même si vous
voyez pas justement dénis à quelque part
je pense qu'il faut quand même être
capable d'en profiter il faut se répéter
que c'est pas tous les gens qui vont qui
ont être sensible aux piqûres de guêpes
au point d'en décider mais je pense que
de se promener dans les sentiers c'est
une précaution
l'autre chose c'est de faire en sorte
que les grecs ne nous prennent pas pour
des flammes et je m'explique ce que si
on porte des parfums ont peuplé fixatif
c'est sûr que ça attire les moustiques
mais ça attire aussi les gars et de
porter des vêtements clairs ou des
vêtements cas qu'ils font en sorte que
légales sont moins attirés par l'évêque
par vos vêtements que des vêtements de
couleur et si qu'est-ce qu'on fait par
exemple si un adulte ou un enfant est
attaqué par des led dans cette situation
là les gens pu intervenir les
secouristes ont pu intervenir rapidement
on n'est peut-être pas toujours dans des
situations intervenir qu'est ce qu'on
doit faire
la première chose c'est de s'assurer que
les gens ne sont pas allergiques on
gagne parce que obtenant exposé porté
d'abord une carte est d'abord un
bracelet deux ans qu'on est allergique
aux gab donc ça ça permet de savoir que
les gens on certainement avec eux une
seringue d'adrénaline comme vous l'avez
mentionné pital ans le fameux hepburn et
s'ils ne sont pas allergiques et qu'ils
se font piquer mais à ce moment là
la première chose ce qui n'est pas
facile mais qu'on se fait dire toujours
par les gens qui travaillent dans en
forêt c'est de bouger le moins possible
vous allez me dire que c'est pas facile
quand on se fait piquer mais comme les
guerres ne voient pas très ne voit pas
très clair
elle se fit au mouvement donc si vous
bougez beaucoup elles vont elles vont
vous piquez plus donc mais une fois
qu'on ait piqué c'est vraiment appliquer
de la glace de faire en sorte d'avoir
par exemple de benadryl ou un autre anti
histaminique gens ne me mets y en a
plusieurs
et puis peut-être d'avoir de la lotion
calamine et si ce n'est pas suffisant à
ce moment le faut quand même consulter
si jamais on s'aperçoit que les dames va
en augmentant peu importe l'endroit où
ont été piqués bien dans ce qu'on
reprend c'est qu'on doit transporter c3
c3 produit là c'est peut-être plus
prudent de transporter avec soi
très bien merci beaucoup absolument je
pense que l'élément important
brigitte juste pour terroriser les gens
qui sont allergiques vérifier la date de
perrin il faut que les gens vérifie la
date de péremption de leur équipe elle
parce que souvent les gens se promènent
avec des seringues sont passés d'ap bien
alors sur ses sages conseils
merci beaucoup docteur johanne blais au
revoir merci brigitte s'en va